now inside Ukraine both sides continue
to exchange Heavy Artillery fire as
they prepare for new offenses many
civilians are caught in the crossfire
raymondocencio visited a village in the
South that is often hit by Russian Rockets
seventy-year-old Natalia Koga never
imagined War would hit her backyard
a gift from Russia she says debris from a grad
rocket like these fired from russian-controlled
Ukrainian territory a roof in tatters a door
blown from its hinges a wall demolished kogut
lives just next door when this house was
hit what did you feel what happened big
big lotions the Earth was
shaking and so was my house
at about 7 A.M when this home was hit luckily
there was no one inside but not every family not
every household was lucky in this Village Victor
Carlin and his wife Luba both 44 lost their lives
now orphaned their teenage daughter sneijana
and her seven-year-old brother in intensive
care this fall removed farming Village has no
apparent strategic value since the war started
half of this Village's 600 people have fled their
children Spirited Away mostly elderly left behind
Victor and Luba are the first deaths
in this community caught between two
armies how do you want them to be remembered
the whole village respected them so much
for me they were the best life is fragile
and death random here on the edge of War for CBS
mornings raymie inocencio Solon Chucky Ukraine